welcome to this special edition of
Hannity the left agenda
I'm Jeanine Pirro and tonight for Sean
for the hour we'll show you how
Democrats the deep state and the media
are all working together against
President Donald Trump first we'll
address the special counsels partisan
probe into Russian collusion while this
administration pushes a sound
conservative agenda
Muller's witch-hunt is dividing the
country and wreaking political havoc day
after day meanwhile Attorney General
Jeff Sessions is nowhere to be found
he's recused himself from all things
Russia almost immediately after taking
office and now the relationship between
President Trump and his absence the
Attorney General is it an all-time low
today the president mock sessions on
Twitter writing quote Department of
Justice will not be improperly
influenced by political considerations
Jeff this is great what everyone wants
so look into all of the corruption on
the other side including deleted emails
Comey lies and leaks Muller conflicts
mccabe struck the page or by ze' abused
Christopher Steele and his phony and
corrupt dossier the Clinton Foundation
illegal surveillance of Trump campaign
coercion collusion by Dems and so much
more open up the papers and documents
without redaction come on Jeff you can
do it the country is waiting
former House Oversight Committee
Chairman jason Chaffetz is slamming
sessions for perpetuating our two-tiered
system of justice take a look Donald
Trump is right and Jeff Sessions is
wrong Jeff Sessions to say he hasn't had
done any political considerations he's
totally false he hasn't done nothing to
go after what Congress has been asking
for and giving the documents up he has
done nothing to pursue what is known to
be false statements to Congress I was
the chairman of the Oversight Committee
and Bob Goodlatte the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee we sent a letter
over to the Department of Justice asking
look if Hillary Clinton lied under oath
never gave a response that's because of
politics not because he's not doing he's
just not doing his job
even Senator Lindsey Graham a longtime
sessions ally is questioning his ongoing
tenure as Attorney General
take a look every president deserves an
attorney general they have confidence in
as to Jeff Sessions I've never met a
finer man he was a great senator he's
great lawyer I think he's been a good
Attorney General but this is not working
so I hope the relationship gets better
if it doesn't I would imagine the
president is going to look for a new
Attorney General cost what's going on is
unsustainable I'm not blaming anybody I
love Jeff Sessions but from my point of
view the country is not being well
served with as much friction meanwhile
with sessions m.i.a Muller's partisan
team of democratic donors have
aggressively targeted Trump and everyone
around him Clinton pollster mark Penn is
writing the Cohen's plea deal is merely
an attempt to set up Trump and The Wall
Street Journal's Kimberly Strasse
highlighted the FBI's one-sided
investigation in a brand new report
writing quote the country has watched
the FBI treat one presidential campaign
with kid gloves the other with
informants warrants and eavesdropping
joining us now to break all of this down
is Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi
the author of The New York Times
bestseller the Russia hoax the elicits
team to clear Hillary Clinton and frame
Donald Trump Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett and former Clinton pollster and
adviser mark Penn or a good evening to
all of you I'm going to start with with
what jason Chaffetz said that we just
heard on that sound where he talked
about sending a letter to Jeff Sessions
and saying he never got a response with
respect to his investigation of all of
the wrongdoings or apparent wrongdoings
of the Clinton campaign and I'll go to
you Attorney General Pam Bondi is
Muller's probe of one-sided probe well
of course it is because they're only
looking at the President of the United
States
and that's that is their target anyone
who gets in the way is collateral damage
that's what they're doing but all of
these other issues have to be examined I
mean we live in a nation of laws and we
have got to look at the Clinton emails
everything that you listed in your
opening monologue everything President
Trump said we've got to look at struck
page everything the FISA warrant
everything but especially these FBI
agents who either like Lisa Paige got to
resign or even the ones who are fired
I'm sorry they don't get off that easy
they have to be invested well they have
to be investigated and but Greg you and
I both know that there is no Attorney
General is interested in investigating
him that Jeff Sessions is either an
unwitting Duke or he's incompetent it's
got to be one of the two what are the
fundamental principles of democracies
equal justice under the law it's on the
pediment of the US Supreme Court that's
how important it is but under Jeff
Sessions and the previous Department of
Justice it is nothing more than a
charade the president rightly named more
than a dozen things sessions should be
investigated for especially Hillary
Clinton and her conduct James Comey
twisted the facts contorted the law to
clear her both of them should be in
front of a grand jury something
interesting you gave me two options you
said Jeff Sessions as either an
unwitting dupe or incompetence
yes or could it be possible that there
are people have convinced him that it's
not in his interest to look at potential
problems on the Democratic side that
would go to incompetence because if that
would be corrupt right for political
purposes you are making decisions about
law and justice which are two polar
opposites okay mark Penn I'll go to you
on this you know your your article that
we'll get to in a little bit is
excellent I read it but in terms of you
know your being someone who worked with
the Clintons you know how they work you
know now that it appears or that there
is a deep state here that is protecting
them am i right in
that assumption well I don't know
whether there's a question of whether
they're protecting Hillary Clinton or
not but they sure they sure going after
President Trump that's not that's not
the answer what I'm looking for is if
the woman had a foundation that was not
investigated no one has had there is no
kind of forensic accountant counting
other than by people who are connected
to the Clinton Foundation that along
with money going to the fusion andthat's
campaign funds being paid for a dossier
that's totally fake shouldn't she be
looked at well look every schoolchild
knows when you look at this that the
most cursory tools and investigations
were done on the allegations against the
Clinton in the Clinton cache and you're
seeing the absolute entire state
machinery of prosecutors FBI CIA all
combined going after Trump so there's no
question that there's an unequal scale
here than almost everybody in America
sees so then what do we do about it Pam
I mean you're an attorney general how do
you resolve this kind of thing well and
again we know we're not in a perfect
world but given all of our backgrounds
in a perfect world what should be
happening right now Hillary Clinton
should be in receipt of a target letter
Huma Abedin should be in receipt of a
target letter all of these people and
frankly the American public shouldn't
really know what's going on in a clean
honest investigation so that's what
should be going on they should be under
active investigation right now
yeah but that is to replace Jeff
Sessions look when you have lost the
confidence of your boss the president
United States when you've breached that
trust the good and honorable and right
thing to do is to submit your letter of
resignation and that's what Jeff
Sessions should have done a long time
ago he apparently did it a year ago but
the president at the time felt it was
unwise to accept well that's that that's
president Trump I mean he gives everyone
a chance I mean ya know you didn't even
look at the one who just wrote the book
I gave her a chance and it you know he
believes in people he believes are
raising people up but you know what I'm
gonna go to you mark on your on your
article where you write about Cohen's
deal is an attempt to set up Trump all
right so we now know that Michael Cohen
has pled guilty and at the end of the
plea or one of the last police had to do
with the reference to campaign finances
what would your take on that how does it
set up the president look I think given
what the it seems the prosecutors found
for a probably Cohen would of pled
guilty to the Lindbergh kidnapping had
they asked him to I I think at the end
of the day they said look plead guilty
to this will reduce your sentence
we won't go after your wife I think that
was even now I understand on the table
and those things that he pled guilty to
are not crimes so by getting him to
plead guilty they can now create an
unindicted co-conspirator conspiracy
kind of theory for impeachment on
something that's not a crime this was
established with Clinton it was
established with Edwards very clearly
when even the FEC ruled that these
payments were not campaign contributions
and frankly had they paid them out of
the campaign they'd probably be indicted
for misuse of campaign funds for
personal purposes well there's no
question about what Mark is saying Pam
and that is that you know if you paid
for it for personal purposes out of your
own money I mean there's no campaign
violation they want to interpret it as
meaning who's trying to meddle with the
2016 election I find that stunning as a
prosecutor we see it we see CEOs we see
corporate executives all the time who
women want to women men want to extort
money from them and they have always my
advice is go to the police but they
never want to go to the police because
they have families or it could affect
their stocks so what they do is they
hire a private attorney and with that
attorney they do a lock solid
non-disclosure and that's a good
attorney this is a bad attorney who
represented his client poorly get all
the members of Congress who paid money
to accusers sexual-harassment and in
exchange for NDA's now obviously would
benefit them in their reelection but no
prosecutor ever accused them of a
that's very interesting yeah for all
those people who paid off but you know
the young interns and whenever they
sexually arrest with our tax payers
money talk to me to remind you talk to a
career lawyer of the Department of
Justice who has since left he spent half
of this time on campaign violations he
said this isn't a crime it's not a
campaign violation and it's outrageous
that Jeff Sessions in rod Rosen Stein
would have author authorized a plea
guilty for a non crime and the truth is
mark that there is no civil or criminal
precedent to bring charges on something
like this is that not correct there
there is look the precedent was Edwards
and and he both got off in the FEC ruled
that these payments were not properly
campaign payments and so all the donors
were look look just think about it for a
minute one of them he's accused of
coordinating not actually even making
the payment and imagine if Michael Evan
Eddy coordinated a payment to stormy
Daniels with CBS to air it to help
Hillary then that would have to be a
campaign contribution just as a payment
not to air it would be a campaign
conscious actually which is why the
whole thing's absurd that the whole
thing is absurd and in the end you know
is is Lady Justice did she have it in
for Donald Trump and are there two
systems of justice in this country I'll
ask both of you 30 seconds that's what
we're seeing that's clearly what we're
seeing we're seeing a vendetta against
the president in the United States
because he won an election fair and
square
you know what's interesting Pam and you
and I both been prosecutors I mean you
know you we have to be believers if we
weren't believers we wouldn't be doing
the jobs that you're doing that I did
it's you know and it is so frustrating
because this is not the way justice is
supposed to work you know and especially
when you see a guy like Michael Cohen we
all know he is a zero as a witness he's
useless that guy there was a witness and
a lawyer right he's told so many
different stories how many stories yes
go ahead bring partisans have ripped the
blindfold off of Lady Justice or she's
looking for the bandages and they have
jumped on the scales of Jeff
and they have tipped it in their favor
for political purposes that is anathema
to our rule of law and the system of
just so given that don't you think that
if we get no justice in our justice
system will we get justice in the 2018
elections quick yes or no mark well look
I thought for President Clinton oh right
look we all get justice every time
people vote instead of having our
politicians blocked with prosecutors no
way - no good answer